you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video to
go go here so far in the how big series
we've seen the size of Google Samsung
Group Tesla and Facebook and cooperated
all of those companies were either
massive or highly innovative but to go
bigger than even Samsung we have to
travel outside the realm of technology
entirely prepare to meet one of the
biggest Giants in companies Walmart ever
heard of it well let me jog your memory
Walmart is a multinational retail store
that has 2.2 million employees that's
almost 10% of the entire Australian
population yep 1 out of every 10 people
in Australia in addition to this 90
percent of all Americans live within 15
miles of a Walmart so how did all of
this happen in this video we'll take a
look at how the company began and then
look at some interesting facts about the
company and finally we'll take a look at
Walmart's mind-blowing size the story of
Walmart is really a testament to just
one man Sam Walton born in 1918 Sam was
a small-town boy growing up on a farm in
Oklahoma later on during the Great
Depression Sam's family moved to
Missouri during college he was noted as
being a very versatile boy one of the
rare people that knew all the janitors
by their first name later on Sam would
carry these same values of respecting
everyone no matter what they look like
or who they were into Walmart I
personally would like to see many of our
people settle down in Walmart's like
Bentonville Arkansas
for instance and and plant their roots
and get their home paid for and become
leaders in their community in 1942 he
served in world war ii as a security
supervisor and rose to the rank of
captain after the war in 1945 at the age
of 26 Sam ran a chain of variety stores
and was extremely successful and by 1962
he opened up his first store under the
Walmart name in Arkansas this store
strongly carried Sam's belief in
small-town values and a strong sense of
community but as you would expect it
wasn't all smooth sailing
here's how the first opening day of
Walmart went according to an eyewitness
back in 1962 I I thought to myself this
is this is absolutely the worst discount
store or a retail store that I've ever
seen
Sam bought a couple of truckloads of
watermelons and he'd stacked them up
across the front of the store he had
donkey rides for the kids out on the
parking lot and what he didn't
anticipate is that the temperature was
about 110 degrees in Harrison that day
and the watermelons began to pop and
that watermelon juice began to run over
the parking lot and the donkeys did what
donkeys do you can imagine what it
looked like the thing I didn't realize
about Sam though and the people who were
involved in those early days in Walmart
is that they had a quality that I
haven't seen in many people or in many
companies and that was that there was
never a day went by that they didn't
improve something the 1970s was the
decade of growth for Walmart and by 1979
they had reached their first billion
dollar year the company's ethos was to
provide the lowest prices in retail for
rural areas in the 1980s the company
really didn't look back Walmart took
over many other discount stores and
franchises as an indication of its size
in 1987 Walmart had built the largest
private satellite communications network
in the whole of the United States
despite the immense growth and old age
Sam made it his mission to visit as many
Walmart stores as he could
sadly Sam passed in 1992 and towards the
end of the 20th century Walmart had
completely lost that small-town feel and
had drifted its focus to benefit more
effective business practices as a result
they became the absolute Giants we know
of today today Walmart is ridiculously
large much bigger than Sam Walton could
have ever imagined here are some facts
to put things into perspective at
Walmart Americans spend 36 million
dollars every hour every day this works
out to 21 thousand dollars of profit
every minute with a profit margin of 6%
strangely enough in the year 2000
Walmart was sued a total of four
thousand eight hundred and fifty one
times or about once every two hours the
average family of four spends over four
thousand dollars a year at Walmart okay
so that's just the surface we see that
Walmart is absolutely huge but let's dig
a little bit deeper
how big is Walmart exactly well
Walmart brought in four hundred and
eighty five billion dollars revenue in
2014 which is twenty billion more than
Austria's GDP Walmart top excellent
Mable in the fortune 500 for a second
year making more revenue than Apple
Target Amazon coca-cola Macy's and Walt
Disney combined for a perspective
Walmart makes 180 billion dollars more
than Samsung in revenue if Walmart were
a country it would be the 26 largest
economy in the world one in every four
dollars Americans spend on groceries is
spent at Walmart just in one week
Walmart serves more than 200 million
customers and more than ten thousand
four hundred stores in 27 countries so
how big is Walmart physically well if he
added up all the store space it would
stretch over 900 million square feet
that's a hundred and fifty percent
bigger than Manhattan
Walmart's parking lots alone take up
roughly the size of Tampa Florida four
of the 10 richest Americans are Walton
family members they're worth more than
30 billion dollars each according to
Bloomberg billionaires index and finally
the last fact of all Australia doesn't
even have a Walmart okay so hopefully
you start to see the real size of
Walmart here it might have been a little
bit bigger than you first would have
thought I was actually surprised at some
of those facts myself so what do we take
away from all of this
well once again as we've seen in other
videos the determination and
perseverance of just a single soul can
really make an incredible difference
also if you look at it when it company
starts buying and taking over the
competition in such a manner as Walmart
does I think we're beginning to reach
the size of too big anyway I want to
thank you for watching and hopefully
you've learned something from this video
and if you did please feel free to
subscribe to my channel there's plenty
of other interesting stuff on here so
that's enough for me this has been - go
go thanks for watching cold fusion I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys
thinking